We're learning more and more about the absolute
fury that overtook Donald Trump after seeing
one of his two impeachment attorneys
yesterday, Bruce Castor aimlessly wander
through his personal background, the political
preferences of his parents, praise of senators,
a discussion of prerevolutionary war, British
law, really everything but the subject matter
of the impeachment during his opening statements
yesterday, which lasted about 50 minutes rather
than opening statements, the opening to the Day
one proceedings to determine whether the Senate
has the jurisdiction to try a president that is
no longer in office. As we talked about yesterday,
the Senate voted 56 to 44 that, yes, they can
have the impeachment trial. There's a report from
CNN that Donald Trump was, quote, deeply
unhappy with the performance of Bruce Castor.
Multiple sources familiar with Trump's reaction
said to CNN that Trump was borderline screaming
as Bruce Castor was failing humiliatingly,
embarrassingly on global television yesterday, and
particularly was upset that those opening remarks
from Bruce Castor were rambling. Trump's team also
was reportedly confused about the last minute
decision to swap the order of his defense. Caster,
who did the 50 minutes of rambling first, was
actually scheduled to speak after David Schoen and
people around Trump thought that this new idea of
having Bruce Castor go first wasn't a particularly
strong idea. Now, of course, they were right.
How much of it is hindsight bias? I don't know.
But they say that Donald Trump was particularly
upset when the first thing Bruce Castor said when
he got up there was the House managers.
The prosecution did a really great job.
And of course, it was true. It was true that
they did a good job. But it's not typically
what you want your defense counsel to
be admitting. The New York Times also
had a report in which they said that Kastor
getting up there and praising the impeachment
managers was not well received by Donald Trump.
And they reported that some of Trump's legal team
were actually surprised that there would be
raw video shown from the January 6th riots.
This to me, you know, we said when your own
legal team misspells United States as United
States, that should be a signal that maybe they're
not playing with a full deck when it comes to
preparation. And Democrats had been saying for
days, we are going to show video of the riots.
Trump's defenders were saying, well, Trump's
lawyers are going to show videos at some point
of Democrats calling for violence. OK,
well, so everybody knows what to expect.
But reportedly, Trump's legal team was
surprised that there was video of the riots
shown. I sort of half jokingly, five percent
jokingly said during the proceedings yesterday,
does Bruce Castor get fired today by Donald Trump?
Apparently, it's actually something Trump is
considering. The Daily Beast was told by a source
familiar with what was going on that Donald Trump
is considering pulling Bruce Castor from the legal
team altogether, which would put everything on,
in particular on David Schoen, which would
be a of a lot of work, to say the least.
As far as the schedule goes, the impeachment
trial is expected to go through the week and
into next week. There are going to be eight
hours of presentations from the House managers,
eight hours of presentations from Trump's defense
counsel. There will then be it's either four hours
total or four hours per party of questions for
the impeachment managers and defense counsel.
And then there will also be closing statements.
So I'm expecting at least into Monday or Tuesday,
although these things change so quickly that the
plan, the plan may change relatively soon. Trump
furious with Bruce Castor. Understandable.
Why? Why can't Trump just get people who are
adequately prepared to represent him in a way
that's not embarrassing? Maybe it's because
a lot of lawyers know they're probably
not going to get paid by Trump since he
stiffs people on legal bills. I don't really
know the answer, but it just will not stop